so the second part that we're going to
talk about is the basic processing of
such data so let's take a look at the
basic processing of such data and try to
understand what are some of the critical
steps that are required for us to
extract a meaningful matrix of
cell specific
expression of genes and then we'll think
about what are some of the challenges
associated with this process
so
i would separate this process into three
major steps there's a process of
when you align the reeds to the
reference genome basically that's the
idea
number two
you then normalize because you have so
many different cells so you want to
normalize the data
and once you normalize the data you then
want to assign them into particular
clusters right so the idea of clustering
will return to that later how to perform
clustering in a meaningful way
that is the overall kind of
review what are some of the issues that
we're trying to address at each one of
these stages
so let's first of all talk about this
first stage the stage of preparing the
reads aligning them and making sure that
we're only taking reads that are aligned
correctly to the reference
so as in any process of alignment we
will have fast q files right so in this
case we already have fast
associated with each individual cell
we then have to align these
reads to the reference genome and
generate a bam file right what is a bam
file a bam file is the same fast queue
but it now tells us the beginning and
the end of each read from the
perspective of the genome so you have
the starting position and the ending
position on the reference genome now
instead of using here uh actual
individual reads
we now switch to umis right and umis are
adapters for each mrna so umi helps us
determine
how many mrna pieces are present in each
cell so it's like an alternative to the
read so instead of counting reads we
count umis in each
and that gives us a better sense of what
level or what abundance of mrna we
actually observe in more of a biological
sense than
just counting those reads right and so
here you can see
that each
read contains the barcode the umi uh and
so we count these umis
now we have thousands and thousands of
cells right so then the process to count
these umis
has to do with comparing cells to each
other right and and the problem
typically is that we don't have enough
rna mrna material in each cell and so
here we run into some challenges right
and the challenges are going to be to
assign those umis correctly and then to
have as much data as possible so that we
can actually take the high quality data
to make biological interpretations right
because if i
for example want to identify a cell type
by a marker gene
but that gene doesn't have enough mrna
it's hard for me to distinguish between
low expression and a missing data point
right and so that is one of the
challenges that we're going to run into
here at this stage of counting
and so an important part here is to
really
look only for cells that have a
sufficient number of humans that come
from gene coding mrna so typically here
we're going to be looking at just gene
expression not trans level expression so
an important part here is going to be to
fill out
only cells that have a sufficient number
of genes that i can assign an expression
level to them based on the overall
number of
my gene expression
let's take a look again at the overall
process of getting raw files into a
pipeline and getting a matrix at the end
and let's think about what we can do
with that matrix after this part
so first of all we need to identify
what essentially are we trying to get it
and we're trying to get a table
expression
so instead of samples we're going to
have genes so typically in a table of
expression you have genes
and
samples here we're going to have a
transpose table and we're going to have
cells and genes
and once we have only for cells that we
have sufficient data
for those specific
cells once we have a sufficient matrix
we want to check for artifacts right and
those artifacts are going to again help
us prepare a better table of expression
and that table of expression will be
uh you know as many cells are going to
be filled with numbers and not zeros and
that major challenge dependent on these
factors of data preparation
once we have that just like we do in
bulk rna-seq we're going to normalize
the data because we know that the
difference between mrna are not always
coming from biological differences that
could be coming from these technical
variability issues
and finally we want to then understand
difference between groups of cells
so let's now take a look at how do we go
to this downstream analysis which
basically will fall
into
these three major challenges of analysis
clustering annotation and analysis of a
trajectory and we'll talk about some use
cases where these approaches are going
to be most useful
so for clustering one of the major
challenges is going to be how do i
what do i call similarity right these
are going to be heterogeneous samples
and so i have a lot of variation just at
the level of expression i have a lot of
variation inside specific genes at the
level of expression and now when i try
to find differences or similarities
before i can do that because in such a
you know i have again tens of thousands
of cells here right so it's very
difficult to work with such complex data
before i do that i want to reduce the
dimensionality and we'll talk about two
methods t sne and umap to reduce the
dimensionality
and then once i do that i want to
perform a specific type of clustering so
depending on the method that i choose
for dimensionality reduction depending
on how many cells i have and how complex
the data is i can choose
different approaches for clustering
once i
determine that for example this is a
cluster and this is a cluster i need to
annotate them right and annotation means
to assign a cell
typically so when i want to assign a
cell type i want to select marker genes
that are coming from some database from
some publication and this is a major
challenge in single cell rna-seq is
appropriately assigning a cluster that
is based on a statistical analysis of my
data set to a particular of tissue cell
or condition in some cases right a cell
in a condition
and the final kind of analysis that you
can perform in some cases
is to try to determine exactly where in
a trajectory of development a particular
cell group is
now in my sample right so why is this an
important thing and why do we don't why
do we not do this in bulk rna-seq
cells are not static
cells are dynamic
and i have let's say a group of cells
let's say in a tumor right
cells are proliferating actively and
they are found in different stages of
proliferation so even though they are
cellular cells for example they could be
in different stages of differentiation
and i want to oftentimes find a process
that i could find individual cells that
have multiple representations now this
is going to be very appropriate for a
time series data set where i can take
for example
some progenitor cells and i can see
their differentiation over time but
sometimes it's also interesting to see a
process in a complex population of cells
and i know that these are all cells from
the same tissue but i know that they're
differentiating at different rates and
so i'll find some that are in the
beginning and and kind of toward later
stages